[Musique]
nogueira concert d'iron de méthode c'est
tout moi rythmique sera jamais mon père
mais sans les cheveux mal quand même
alors série selon mes statistiques
personnelles vous taclez en moyenne deux
personnes publiques par émission c'est
ouais c'est vraiment très précis et
mercredi dernier vous avez fait exploser
tous les compteurs chez pas ce qui est
arrivé nous avaient mitraillé tout le
monde dans tous les corps de métiers de
ce que les ringards comme un art montiel
fabien lecoeuvre appelle le show
business c'est pas des ringards
mais je les adore en plus évidemment je
regardais l'émission chaque puce et
aient été ou sous forme en poste ou
rambo 2 en 7 minutes de passer de cyril
hanouna à cyril clash ou non
ça commence et que le monde du cinéma
avec les césar avant même la cérémonie
sais pas pourquoi on sentait qu'il
n'allait pas trop regarder au mac on en
rêve tous et au carré convaincre des
gens connaissent vraiment le cinéma et
qui pensent pas qu'à leur gueule je le
nie j'adore canal + oui ma famille et
mes ils retransmettent les césar c'est
très bien parce qu'ils vont faire une
audience de fou mais les césar je mens
karl oculaires et les chéris s'il ya des
quads haute à défaut c'est vrai fond
c'est le foot
vous avez fait une analyse de neymar
mais pas de son style de jeu mais de son
c de nourriture encore plus méchant que
pierre ménès mal
neymar faire c'est le nouveau françois
hollande il est tiré par chez nini tous
les soirs j'ai des boulettes frère je
viens me couper niox nima à mon ami
frère je veux te dire il en mange de
larissa les connaître défoncer les
séries télé et je sais pas ce que vous
faites le saut maintenant le sait que
vous regardez pas les séries de canal +
c'est sûr on va pas dans vision passer
la pommade à tous nos programmes sous
pression sur match il ya plein de syrie
moi je vous dis la vérité
platane la saison la nouvelle saison
platane c'est une sombre mais la
première était très bonne la deuxième il
ya des quads haute a défoncé y avait
contre les français le bouquet final
vous avez tenu à rendre hommage au monde
de la presse
un hommage touchant tous en sept minutes
je rappelle que c'est un torchon
voici.fr c'est un torchon a les mêmes
gens là restent
et alors et au dessus de public.fr
encore plus de la merde c'est voici.fr
c'est de la chasse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais chaud j'ai eu la direction de
canal+ le lendemain non c'est si bien
sûr je leur avais vraiment le platane le
platane de houelle pris dans la gueule
c'est vrai que c'est elle moi c'est top
pattana été très belle china direct et
pourtant ça car et plus eric je l'aurais
vous à regarder rive nord
eric judor ouais pourquoi tu vas me dire
quelque chose s'est passée la cogneuse
j'aime beaucoup je pense pas que veut
dire quelque chose
ah ouais l'approché voilà c'est de la
merde domicile à mon numéro fils de
m'appeler et on se rencontrera aucun
souci d'être honneur en bouffant de
canal + je vous trouve rebelles qu'un
temps mais on dit la vérité donc je le
redis c'est pas parce que des programmes
sur son canal + sur canal plus ce qu'on
va dire du bien c'est pas parce que ce
soit sur tf1 qu on va en dire du mal sur
france 2 on est franchement on dit tout
et c'est pas parce que c'est moi qui
produit moi j'ai produit des grosses
merdes
non mais franchement par exemple j'en ai
plein non sans rigoler si le conseil de
saint césaire mais c'est vrai il ya
plein d'émissions dont le jeu je suis
pas fier de son actuel ou trop chaude
voilà c'est cécilia des émissions que
j'habitais de donner des noms quand même
là de quoi un message pour la bonne
cause cover où elle s'était passé il va
bien marché c'était pas que c'était pas
bien il ya eu quad en haïti il ya quoi
que ce soit les high hashtag ou diez
aussi ces stars l'autre ça doit être le
producteur pascal rappeler même plus
j'ai commencé cette émission mais
coûtent moins bien c'est vrai
en plus ces stars c'est nos amis les
stars c'est la seule chaîne sans rigoler
c'est parce que tu vas voir c'est toi et
ta chance à ses stars ses ou un clip de
maitre gims ou bien maigri frères débat
aucune cohérence c'est n'importe quoi à
mon cas maman tu es un mec qui fait de
la gym deux minutes après tu as un clip
de maître guy et puis après time et
greta raid avec sa pub sans rire et vous
passez d'un programme pour sept ans à un
programme pour des gens morts ces
débrayages a aucune cohérence
il arrive en direct qui font ça et le
mec qui les corps at il ajouté
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça un petit peu comme quand on est
à l'école on me connaît
mais moi ma mémoire devient dès lors
qu'ils deviennent les mecs ils sont hors
chez les mecs qui font la promo faire
aider pour et c'est sûr et ça continue
on fête ce jeudi ses règles et ses stars
mon père ils pourraient ils font des
classements d'août où mon frère révéler
le classement des dix jeux les plus
écoutées par les mustafi pour casser le
déclassement et chaque semaine ils
songent animatrice rage c'est parce
qu'ils n'ont jamais vu de la même tête
d'où son but sur ses stars on dirait
qu'ils prêtent des gens là lors des
sommets où ces départs et la basse et
des paris très belle famille à ses stars
mais à ce stade avoir du pacte aurait
zappé repas il s'appelle monsieur sabot
le patron de ces stages je tape avec le
mal est pour lui vendre un petit progrès
cela donne j'adore abbaoui ça bouge mais
c'est vrai mais j'aime bien et bon il
était patron d'europe 2 tout ça va chez
le coni permet à christophe l'adorent
non non il est vraiment à fourrure
qu'ils y perdaient sester marche de
mieux en mieux mais je sais pas comment
il fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais il a des couilles bordée de la dore
christophe sabot j'adore ce qu'il fait
lui même avait coûté dans l'humour
vachard de s être continuée super modèle
inconnu coluche et jean michel maire un
travailleur acharné ce qui n'est pas
faux mais c'est un bonheur acharnée
c'est comme j avec fatou il prend des
bombes il continue quand même quoi qu'il
arrive
et comme d'habitude ces réactions assez
vite sur extraordinaire comme tous les
mois c'est quoi c'est le petit jean
michel
le petit jean michel à de petite
capacité de travail mais de grandes
capacités de poèmes
je voulais que ça soit dur pour valérie
benaïm qu'hector ma soeur de sang une
sorte de bourgaud frère le petit jean
michel est ce qu'on appelle un
boute-en-train toujours la vanne au
mauvais moment
les tunisiens on n'est pas fort en
sports aquatiques on va pas se mentir
non mais tu as déjà entendu eux rachid
kallouch au crotoy au droit c'est à nous
au 100 m nage libre
[Musique]
quand on parle de pékin express le petit
jean michel ne manque pas de faire de
l'esprit sur le terrain avec les
chemises de ranger la à cette chaudière
express c'est pas drôle était médecin et
surtout le petit jean michel adore le
comique de répétition
quand on parle du vote du public pour le
concours de danse c'est encore un succès
raymond est toujours en tête que gilbert
montagné qui a voté cette bagnole a fait
tous les jours sur rue
[Musique]
il essaie et bien sûr qu'on se marre
bien franchement ici je vous dise et des
familles où se régalera sont tous les
soirs on en direct on dit des conneries
c'est un bonheur j'en aurais dit pour sa
part un de ses stars c'est que les clips
de ses stars sans rigoler vous savez
parfois ils maintenaient ils vont y
envoient des messages
elle manque un peu de monde que moi des
messages via des messages qui date de
2018 fonctions juste ma mère on a vu on
l'a vu nous aimons la plus regardée
crier stéphanie je t'aime bonal et 2018
et la chine
la chaîne l'a arrêté c'est l'argent des
programmes les boulangers faut quoi ils
ont tout donné a maigri la libye gmac a
saisi la particularité en 25 ans de
carrière il a animé au temps des
missions qu'il a épousé deux femmes avec
vous syrie ne forme un duo de rayer de
bourvil de funès clavier rénaux ou
encore tintin et milou
benji c'est un peu votre saoul douleur
si les linges oleme trop en progrès mais
encore aujourd'hui dans la loge il ya
une attaque non alors varier la taille
dit la vérité c'est vrai je voulais
provoquer vos achats précédents c'est
vrai il m'a provoqué clémente était là
je confirme offert 6 voir un monsieur
comme firme a fait manquer ce qu'il a
fait comme un commissaire il vous a
cherché un peu et vous lui a pété la
gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
actuel chercher un peu vous avez pété la
gueule c'est l'opg de nuit je note que
15 heures de 30° famille et donc voulu
répéter la gare toute façon alors entre
vous il ya quand même une complicité qui
m'a rappelé un programme de ma jeunesse
perdue quand j'étais petit et benny hill
aujourd'hui on à benji il est drôle ça
j'espère merci
[Musique]
c'est presque comme marty mcfly personne
ne le traitent de bouffon à par cyril
hanouna bien sûr vous étiez des femmes
pas du tout l'inventeur du terrain''
monsieur il a été fort à toi tennis au
bouffon ouais il a perdu 6 4 pendant des
mois et des mois ses propos
oui oui c'est ça benji il est courageux
dont il tente quand même de se rebeller
un petit peu je t'expliquerai il n'ya
plus d'appels pendant les pubs très bien
pendant les pubs tu restes avec moins
d'effets rpm est en prison ça se lance
tu n'avais pas non plus bon ben on m'a
pas posé la question
alors alors de le faire tu vois
à propos branco benji les cris de son
patron puisque chaque soir il est quand
même sa vie en danger
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que c'était un fidèle
il est démobilisé à la nuque le grand
plaisir de ciel nacelle créé à bendjé
des problèmes de couple à propos de la
nouvelle sophie cost révèle vite je vais
rassurer votre femme ne t'inquiète pas
il aime que toi voire même sur wat
elle ne me parle que de toi vraiment je
te dis à chaque fois toutes les coupures
pub et sophie et saufs
on sent tout le respect de cyril hanouna
pour benji parce qu'il sait que
sportivement benji c'est un athlète de
haut niveau qu'on appelle des espèces
d'olympia avec dix épreuves sportives
ok je suis là vous jouez maintenant je m
je vais je m en voudrais toi tu vas d'y
jouer avec les chars lourds
[Musique]
non
et ça
bien sûr que des sera bondé mais son
corps n'a pas gelé moi c'est mon ami un
joli c'est moyen des mémoires c'est moi
il a le droit de me traiter aussi il me
traite tout le temps ça va et c'est
plein de marde mandat qui doit traiter
plein de fois tu peux voir c'est vanessa
amical est ce que je le prends très bien
passé mais qu'elles n'ont pas montré
qu'on veut bien sûr broc ont dit non non
c'est pas ton ami